or on problem 38 which of the following
best describes the graph of this system
of equations okay so maybe they're the
same line maybe they're parallel maybe
the only respect in one point to lens
intersecting in only two points well
that's impossible
two lines I mean the other can happen
with curves but that's not gonna happen
with line so we can already canceled out
choice D okay now let's look at these
two if I were to see I have a Y here and
I'm a 5y here let's multiply this top
equation times five and see what it
looks like so if we multiply the
left-hand side by 5 you get 5y I'll do
it up here you get 5y is equal to 5
times minus 2 is minus 10x plus 5 times
3 is 15 so if you multiply the top
equation both sides of it by 5 and it
really doesn't fundamentally change the
line the equation might look different
but the aquit the equality will still
hold in the same universe which is
essentially that line so if you just
multiply both sides by 5 they become the
same equation 5y is equal to minus 10x
plus 15 so they are the same lines so
that's a two identical lines problem 39
and they want us to simplify 5x to the
third over 10 X to the seventh so the
easiest way to think of this or at least
for me I mean well there's a lot of ways
you could do it and we'll do it both
ways this is the same thing as five
tenths times X to the third times X to
the minus seven right 1 over X to the 7
the same thing as X to the minus 7 and
this is equal to 5 tenths is one half
and then here we have the same base and
we're multiplying so we can add the
exponents 3 plus minus 7 is minus 4 so X
to the minus fourth power and we could
write that as 1 over 2 times 1 over X to
the fourth or 1 over 2x to the fourth
and that is choice B now you could have
done in other ways
coulda said okay let's see I have a
divide the numerator and denominator by
five so this would have been one this
would have been a two and you say okay
let's divide the numerator the
denominator by X to the third so this
will become a 1 and X to the seventh
divided by X to the third is X to the
fourth you coulda done that one you're
gonna 1 1 over 2 X to the fourth either
way or you could have even said you
didn't have to go to this step you could
have said okay I can just when I'm
dividing with the same base I can just
subtract the exponents so 3 minus 7 was
minus 4 either way all of them would
have been valid ways to approach this
problem problem 40 this looks like a
simplification they would say they write
4x squared minus 2x plus 8 minus x
squared plus 3x minus 2 is equal to so
the key here is just to realize this is
a minus right so you can kind of view it
as a plus minus 1 times this whole thing
so we're just going to distribute that
out so let me so this is equal to 4x
squared minus 2x plus 8 and now we
distribute this minus over this whole
expression so minus times x squared is
minus x squared minus x 3x positive 3 XS
- 3 X the minus 1 times negative 2 well
now they cancel and you get a plus 2
right we switch the sign on everything
here because they're all being
multiplied by this negative 1 okay now
we can simplify so let's take the x
squared terms first so we have a 4x
squared we have a minus x squared so 4x
squared minus x squared is 3x squared
all right 4 minus 1 is 3 then let's do
our X terms we have a minus 2x we have a
minus 3x so minus 2 minus 3 that's a
minus 5x minus 5x and then last we have
our constants we have 8 plus 2 8 plus 2
is 10 so 3x squared minus 5x
+10 and that is choice D problem 41 okay
they say the sum of two binomial
amiright let me copy this one is
interesting the sum of two binomials is
5x squared minus 6x so binomial is just
a polynomial of the two terms if one of
the binomials is 3x squared minus 2x
what is the other binomial so they're
saying that so this binomial is one of
them so they're saying 3x squared minus
2x and when you add that to some other
binomial and I don't know let me just
write that as a and there is no constant
term here and there is no constant term
here so I'm assuming that vice and it
has to be a binomial right there's only
two terms so I'm assuming my two terms
are an x squared term and an X term
because that's the only terms that are
involved in both of these so let's say
my binomial is ax squared plus BX all
right this is the mystery binomial and
their sum is equal to this up here is
equal to 5x squared minus 6x now let's
see what we can do well this is a plus
here so the parentheses really don't
matter we can rearrange this as 3x
squared plus a x squared minus 2x plus B
X is equal to 5x squared minus 6x C 3
plus a 3 x squared plus a x squared
that's the same thing as 3 plus a x
squared and then minus 2x plus BX and we
could swish them around that's the same
thing as plus B minus 2 I just took the
coefficients add them together X I
switched them but we could have written
this in the other order to begin with is
equal to 5x squared minus 6
and now you just compare okay three plus
a if you just look at the x squared
terms three plus a has to be equal to
five right because that's the
coefficient on the x squared term so
three plus a is equal to five subtract
three from both sides you get a is equal
to two and then we have B minus 2 B
minus 2 has to be the coefficient on X
here so it has to be equal to minus six
add two to both sides you get B minus
six plus two is four so the other
binomial just substituting that ax
squared plus BX is two x squared right
two x squared plus BX
oh sorry this is a minus four right
minus 6 plus 2 is minus 4 so plus B X so
minus 4 that's B X and that is choice a
next problem
next problem okay they say which of the
following expressions is equal to this
problem 42 and they write x plus 2 plus
X minus 2 times 2x plus 1 so we have to
simplify this and remember order of
operations multiplication comes first we
have to multiply these two expressions
first so let's do that so this is I'll
rewrite this one over here X plus 2 plus
and now let's multiply this so this is
really when you multiply these two
binomials you're really just doing the
distributive property twice and I got
let me show that to you so this is we
could view this as X minus 2 times 2x
plus X minus 2 plus 1 so I'm just
distributing the X minus 2 times each of
these terms so I could write this as X
minus 2 times 2x plus plus X minus 2
times the 1 right all right now we can
just simplify that by doing the
distributive property again
this is X plus 2 plus let's distribute
the 2x times
these two x times X is 2x squared 2x
times minus 2 is minus 4x plus what
we're distributing a 1 1 times anything
is just itself so plus X minus 2 plus X
minus 2 and let's see what we can do we
only have one x squared term so let's
write that down
2x squared so 2x squared and then our X
terms we have a plus X a minus 4x and a
plus X so we have 1 minus 4 is minus 3
plus 1 is minus 2 so it's minus 2x and
then let's see we have a positive 2 2
minus 2 they cancel out so we're left
with 2x squared minus 2x and that's
choice a choice a probable 43 I think we
can fit in here let me copy and paste it
okay copy it and now pasting it okay it
says a volleyball court is shaped like a
rectangle let me draw that well I didn't
want to draw it filled in like that but
fair enough shape like doors shaped like
a rectangle it has a width of X meters
and a length of 2x meters okay so it's
with his accent it's let me write this
could be X and this would be 2x because
it's longer which expression gives the
area of the court in square meters well
the area is just the width times the
length right so it's just x times 2x
which is equal to 2x squared right
that's the same thing as 2 times X times
X which is same thing as 2x squared and
that's choice B anyway see in the next
video